Alright, now we do have to define a couple more words that are related to cryptography because...
All right, now we do have to define a couple more words that are related to cryptography because these are used extensively today in certain cryptography applications, but the first is the word stagnography and something related to it is what we call the null cypher, but if you look at the word stagnography itself, it simply means hiding something within something else.
And so there's different ways that you can hide something within something else. Like for example, we have what's called physical stagnography and that could be as simple as hiding your password on a sticky note underneath your keyboard. For example, any physical method of hiding a message is an example of stagnography and how it relates to cryptography is if you remember the definition of cryptography, it means turning something into a secret.
So for using hiding something within something else in order to keep something as a secret, it's a form of cryptography, but specifically it's known as stagnography.
All right, so as I've mentioned, there's different methods to achieve stagnography. One of them is physical stagnography, but we also have what's called modern stagnography.
Modern stagnography will simply use modern techniques, technology, for example, hiding a message within another picture file or slack space on hard drives, for example, any method that uses technology to hide something within it can be referred to as modern stagnography.
Now something that has been seen on the example is what we call a null cipher, and this is a pretty popular way to hide something within something else.
And a null cipher hides a message in plain text, but within other plain text. In other words, we have a message that is all in plain text, but there is hidden text within that.
And so we have an example of this, and there are some famous examples of stagnography that we've seen, for example, in the past.
But if you look at, for example, this entire message that we've got up on the slide here, if you look at the first letter of each of the words, it'll spell the secret message that we've hidden within other text that is all in plain text.
So remember, the definition of a null cipher is hiding a message within another message, but everything is in plain text.
So if you look at the first letter of each of these, it spells out security through obscurity. That's the message that we've hidden.
You know, there's all kinds of examples of null ciphers that we've seen in the past, but this is a pretty good one, as you can see.